tried to put some early pressure on Primo and
now it's tle poso again away from dvorac he'll
play it back to the line for Eric Johnson with
a Shot Pat sa but the rebound is there and it's
covered up and Eric Robinson looking for that
rebound for is Jaden strel former North Easter
defenseman we mentioned off the top former
teammate of Deon Levi out there now Levi
big St far post on on ahead as he got over to
his left Canadians again with a takeaway Evans
tried to center it watch the moving by Anderson
Evans over play around to the near point and a
blown tire there by mat three on one for
Buffalo Skinner Tage Thompson fire Circle
holds it can't work it in no side of the net and
Casey midd couldn't tap it in power for Victor
olers to the goal line B it in front that kind
opposal robbed there by Primo now turns puts it
off the board that kind of nicely Falls to
Middle stack trying to feed it through for
Skinner Skinner comes right back to him save not
once but twice by Primo playing it to the goal
line now Benson in front kyoso stopped again and
then olon tried to go top shelf and went over the
neck still no score in the game Skinner
for power out of the corner the puck comes
into the slot here's Caufield with a
Chance what a Save By Devin Levi the
cousins careful not to take a penalty
of kova savage carrying the puck and
then a good job by samelson forcing the
play outside the line Montreal 7 seconds
away from a man Advantage kovich down the
right side s it they score deflected in oh
no yeah bad thing there Dan still
two seconds left on the Montreal
penalty you see just drives to the net there the
shot comes from the side he just redirects it just
catches Far Side you just slides that one through
you see the redirecting it goes right underneath
the Blocker of Devon Levi right there and just
inside the far post that's the first goal of the
game so the Canadians take the one- nothing lead
and with the major penalty on the board they still
have them man ADV and they score again Suzuki
walks into the zone and let it rip and beats Levi
and that quickly it's a two nothing Montreal lead
with 647 to go here in the second period at DIS
saers standing up there just watch him coming bang
right here just kind of opened up Kyle aosa tries
to get a piece of him he gets a stick on him and
that is it but he just gets it down to that hash
marks and then he use Eric Johnson as a screen he
pulls it into the feet of Eric Johnson takes the
quick shot wa out kyoso as the Savers with five
and a quarter to go in the second period want
to keep it here and not any more of a hores it's
Anderson trying the glove of Levi and Deon Levi
says I'm right here and I've got that do you want
a night off when the games are going yeah really
yeah okay I do right in front oh my goodness
Primo with a big save over at that far post
Now power dumps it in and it's clut down by
Freo left at the side of the [Applause] goal
the Canadians look to find a way out T Thompson
intercepts that Thompson top of the far Circle
Skinner in Fr [Applause] St takes Thompson look
for his Lin M and Jeff Skinner with the Finish
slides it home and it is is indeed now a 2-1
Montreal lead with an early third period goal a
little confusion in the neutral zone there but tat
Thomson does a nice job just curling up as Jeff
Skinner collides with the man at the Blue Line
and he gets up and then he rides right through
but nice job by Kate Thompson finding Skinner but
look at how quick he gets it off it gets through
his stick bang he gets the forehand and the shot's
taken Anderson has to reach for that one power
able to take it away from him 13 and 1 half to go
in the third period Montreal 2 Buffalo one here's
the turnover in front rebound scores captain
my captain kyoso has tied the game of [Music]
two and you just see here there's Owen power
he's got the puck going to go D to D here
with Conor Clifton he LS it up chips it in but
continues to go able to steal that puck creates
the opportunity and then you see the two Montreal
Canadians kind of come together in front both go
down and kosa just following it up right there
I'm sorry they don't go down the one goes down
the other stands goenda Primo not in the middle
of the net vior olison who had the initial Push-Up
ice can't keep it in the zone and the Canadians
break it out they've got three on this Rush two
on one now here's Suzuki back door pass Levi
oh my goodness he may have gotten some help
over there on the second moment of it but Devin
Levi here's Suzuki Coffield on the two-on one
the pass across there's the shot slapping for
it over on the other side KBS plays it back
to the line Rasmus dolene right forwards walks
in holds it CR L and fires it that hits a post
444 to go on the period Coffield from the left
Circle download back door play oh my goodness
oh my Levi he got over to that far post now
back in front and that shot is wide Skinner
over on this right side Canadians get it out and
with some room here look out to VX back by Levi
106 to go tied it to third period Canadians
off the draw play it to the corner will not
get it out great STI play by Dylan cousins
Skinner and cousins Skinner takes the shot
and Primo wasn't sure exactly where he had it
but he felt it off the boards in the Buffalo
Zone ahead to mle St he gets to Center and
across the Montreal line slides it across to
Thompson comes to the middle Thompson shakes and
bakes and the shot by Middle St patted Away by
Primo we'll start the shoot out Thompson from
Center Ice stick in his right hand now makes
his way to the far Circle between the circles
Thompson stuck by Primo Tates Thompson here he
tries to make quick little move there just before
he takes the shot to go go to his forehand Suzuki
wide to the left followed by Levi Suzuki decks
Levi poek save and a [Music] beauty Suzuki's
in he's right on top of the blue paint and as
soon as you get the blue paint Levi knows he
can reach that spot and he's just able to poke
it away ol into the right Circle works his way
in scores Victor gison in the shootouts just
watch him he's going to fake that b backand and
then as soon as he does pulls it back across and
takes the shot boom and up Caufield again to the
same left Circle against Levi Coffield between
the wickets open him up enough and it's one a
piece of the shootout you see Levi how far he's
out but he gets him opened up there you see the
space in between the two pads and the five hole
and he finds that hole quick and hard but right
now it's Arizona native against Ste Levi to the
right Circle and with speed yon him sh scores 22
in the shootout and then kind of puts the brakes
on look at there he cuts in puts the brakes on
shows forehand and then fakes the back and then
strong right there on the forehand gets it past
Devon Levi's glove but turkus coming to the same
Circle right side not a lot of speed trying to
open him up and that time M Creo says I've seen it
and I read it made the stop derky is coming down
the side here's looking to go far side but you
see it just bought that last little stick handle
right there just bought enough time for Primo
Savers need a save from Levi Levi will up sovi
scores and the Canadians in the shootout
get the extra point wi it 3 to2 yeah